we are going all the way down memory
lane like we are so
far like we're going to run out of gas
we are so far down
i want to invite larry our producer in
he is going to
play you a little surprise larry i want
my surprise larry
i want your reaction she fights social
injustices
ignorance and um
oh no no false pretenses and uh
innocent friends mary
in the beginning i look really nasty
pretty much like this we have like the
unibrow you'll want a close-up of this
it's pretty amazing um it's kind of like
my
my tom snyder tribute we get the glasses
and the the frumpiness at the end i made
over looked nice you know cut the hair
loose the glasses voila you know
new look i was not invited to prom
that's true 100 true tackling that next
week
what goes through your head when you
look back at a 19 year old rachel
the thing i don't like the most is i i
do the same thing that
no offense but most teenagers do where
i'm under the impression clearly in that
video that i'm
far smarter than i am i'm really not i
didn't know anything
rachel i think you might be an exception
rather than the rule i mean
the way that you talked about how and
i'm not trying to be super serious here
because obviously it's a lighthearted
movie but
you talk about how laney is a woman who
is
fighting injustices she stands for what
she believes in
do you ever think back on how important
it was
to be a woman playing women like josie
like laney and how we need more roles
like that today
we absolutely do i i have a daughter and
i recognize more than ever how important
those roles are
and i love that i can step into those
shoes
i think i'm sort of like an unlikely
hero in that sense like
i'm very small and you wouldn't think
that you know you would think if you
look to me that i could be pushed around
but it's like
you poke fun of the unibrow you invited
the camera to come get a
close-up was that a prosthetic
because we sometimes had to jump back
and forth like pre
and post makeover i will never forget
the day i had to go
to a general meeting after we were
filming with unibrow
and i left it on and i forgot and i
they don't know what the movie's about
right and you can't okay like you can't
see it in the movie that bad
because like we have the glasses on and
lighting is kind
but let's just say that in person you
can see it
and it was like didn't get that movie
it's fine
but i didn't get it can i have the last
dance
no
you can have the first i want to know
honestly if you were like the rest of us
if it was tough to go to work every day
because
you had insane crushes on freddy prince
jr
paul walker dule hill i mean the
gorgeous men in that movie just kind of
run rampant i mean
someone really just was like it's in my
birthday
god there were zero
uh like new relationships out of that
movie and the funny thing is we were
shooting in la
and when you work in town it doesn't
have that same like
summer camp type vibe but when you're on
location it's more like
well let's all go to dinner where are we
and that kind of thing but when you're
in l.a everyone goes back to their
regular lives but it's been amazing like
being able to see
people again over the years working on
psych with delay
catching up with freddie at a convention
just you know you name it i love how
small
our town is sometimes i want to
transition into another project
that is so beloved of course
babysitter's club
which just had its reboot run on netflix
i'm curious if you've had a chance to
watch it and what you thought
i want to wait until my daughter will
watch it with me and she's six and so
she's still annoyed if i tried to make
her watch
something that's not animated i'm so
happy for these girls um
i had the pleasure of speaking with uh
malia baker who plays marianne now
and oh my goodness she's just such a
remarkable young woman
talk about like a role model and just a
sense of sensitive like
thoughtful incredibly intelligent person
like they could not have cast that role
any better
were there ever conversations about you
making a little you know wink to the
camera
or being involved my phone didn't rank
for that let's let the the the girls
behind this
incarnation of the franchise let's let
them get their canoe
shirley out of the water and then i'll
come in
in season 12 and just you know like the
guidance counselor who says some really
wise things
that's you that's me i don't know if
you're keeping track but april
2021 is gonna mark 20 years
since josie and the pussycats and i know
you guys got together a couple years ago
you did that really fun
fan event are there conversations is
there anything that you're
cooking up or things you're thinking of
of how we can celebrate too as a cast
i i love that you think that someone
like me who's never
gotten it together to send out a holiday
card
has thought about this like you're
giving me so much credit right now
look i think i think as a fan it's like
our secret fantasy that like there's
still a group chat between you
and tara and rosario dawson and that you
guys
me and brie who played stacy in the
original bsc texted me two hours ago
uh marla sokoloff um i played cookie
making my mortal
enemy from that is his dear friend and i
could
uh i could give you 20 more instances
that would make you super happy but
no i don't see tara and rosario really
except for
at that reunion if you have a day free
in april 2021
would you be about to do another reunion
get together celebrate
the 20-year anniversary absolutely i
think that
that movie it just dare i say it only
gets better
it really does i have to tell you i i
was doing a little research
and the director of the movie revealed
that
beyonce aaliyah and lisa left i lopez
all audition for the film did you get a
chance to read with them or or be in the
room with them ever
i would remember if i was in a room with
beyonce
yes wait bow down
um totally uh
yes i did meet uh left eye
i did not meet aaliyah left i was just
like
she just seemed like transported from
like like she was already
music royalty you know what i mean but
yeah she had an
incredible presence and so beautiful
look i mean
with the success of riverdale and people
still being so invested
in the the whole brand of josie and the
pussycats
would you be ever interested in
rebooting it or what do you think a
reboot could look like
i don't think that they would want or
need me to to touch that but
again like i'm in support of it i never
i never hate on it when these things
happen because i've
i've been the remake myself sometimes
you know i did a movie of
tom sawyer a million years ago and i
wasn't the first person to play becky
thatcher i don't think so it's just like
you know you're just you're not always
gonna be first and you have to uh
yeah you have to pass the torch
gracefully was that jonathan taylor
thomas
oh yes are you in touch with him i feel
like we don't see any of him really
in entertainment i i feel like no one
has seen that totally awesome guy uh
in forever because he's off like living
the life of a
super just smartypants grown-up who does
a real fancy job now you sit here before
me today
more goddess-like than ever more
talented
you have really tapped into your
instincts behind the camera
we have never heard something bad about
you
ever not at least publicly and when
you've been working for as long as you
have
it's hard to avoid the the pitfalls of
childhood stardom what do you think the
key has been
to you avoiding all of that like
everyone i spent a
good chunk of especially my late teens
and twenties making some pretty epic
mistakes if i wrote a tell-all memoir i
could put some stuff in there that you'd
be like oh do you think it's because we
didn't have like
the ubiquitous presence of like camera i
don't like whenever i meet
young actors and you know if i like work
on their movie or something like that
and people
you know their parents corner me and say
like
how do i keep my kid normal how did how
did you do it how did your parents do it
and i was just unfortunately i was just
never invited to any of those rowdy
parties
i just wasn't i'm not trying to make you
feel bad for me it's probably the reason
i'm
alive rachel i don't believe it you are
so kind
you are absolutely gorgeous you're i
imagine you're very fun to be around
uh i mean so my parents think so
[Music]